bonjour bonjour à tous les deux merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous sur
rtl sur rt france vous a été avec nous
alors blain je ne sais pas si rémy
rebeyrotte est avec nous peut-être dans
quelques secondes anor blain on a on a
vu le chef de l'état à nice hier on l'a
vu déploré l' attaque contre cet élu à
saint pierre et miquelon
la faute aux propos d' emmanuel macron
sur les non vaccinés selon vous
à l'évidence alliance il a rajouté il a
mis de l'huile sur le feu la semaine
dernière mais en vérité ce ne sont pas
que ses propos puisque durant cinq ans
il n'a fait que monter les uns contre
les autres donc effectivement il
il a une politique qui
sélectionne les uns et les autres qui
ont tendance à distribuer les bons et
les mauvais points et donc après se
plaindre des effets qui lie à sur le
territoire c'est
assez risible je dirais même si la
teneur des faits qui se sont déroulés
n'ont absolument rien de drôle parce que
c'est vrai que on parle d'une attaque
d'un élu
et lorsque l'on m'attaque un élu on
attaque la démocratie si on attaque la
démocratie c'est qu'on ne peut plus
discuter dans ce pays et le fait est
qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
débats sont interdits et effectivement
il est très difficile d'évoquer tous les
sujets alors que nous devons être
notamment quand on gère une crise dans
une capacité à discuter à échanger à
poser le pour apposer de contrat prendre
la meilleure décision
on se rend compte que notamment dans la
gestion de la crise sanitaire puisque le
fond de l'histoire est quand même celle
ci c'est que le président de la
république a tout géré de manière
totalement isolé en conseil de défense
c'est à dire totalement en
confidentialité en secret défense et
puis il ne s'est absolument pas entouré
des parlementaires pour véritablement
répliqué sa politique sur le territoire
donc serait canton qu'au député
d'opposition jeu je déplore cette
manière d'agir parce que
le virus contamine le village touche
tout le monde et pour autant les seules
solutions devraient venir de la majorité
et malheureusement on voit bien que la
situation ne s'améliore pas et me
reverras bienvenue dans cette matinale
d'arreter france on parlait des images
de ce député qui a été on a vu des
manifestants lui jeter des algues à la
figure certains disent que les propos d'
emmanuel macron n'ont évidemment pas
amélioré la situation que c'était
prévisible cette violence à l'égard des
élus après ces propos qu'en pensez vous
moi je pense que de toute façon un ses
propos face et au pardon les faits qui
se sont déroulés
sont absolument inacceptable vis-à-vis
d'un collègue alors j'entends bien les
gens qui disent oui mais non en
démocratie lorsque l'on à grèce d'une
manière générale d'ailleurs à nos
concitoyens et lorsqu on agresse en
particulier un élu quelqu'un qui détient
une part d'aller dire de de la
souveraineté nationale inutile de vous
dire que c'est condamnable point point
on peut pas accepter même si évidemment
le droit de manifester d'avoir des
opinions contraires c'était d'ailleurs
rappelé par ma collègue tout de suite on
a tout à fait le droit en démocratie
d'avoir des opinions contraires on peut
pas accepter que ça prenne ses tournures
là que ça prenne ses formes là et là il
n'ya pas barguigner à dire ah bah oui
mais vous comprenez il ya peut-être
une tendance à des battus violemment
dans la société ne peut pas accepter ça
avec vous sauf que emmanuel macron et
chef de l'état une note des
renseignements avait anticipé ces
violences et notamment la remobilisation
justement des antilles passe à cause de
cette phrase provocatrice d' emmanuel
macron alors blanc vous êtes d'accord
avec ce que vient de dire rémy
rebeyrotte il ya de la violence on la
condamne point final bah non pas du tout
bien sûr qu'il faut condamner la
violence là dessus mon cher collègue
vous pourrez ne pas me retrouver je les
dis je le condamne avec la plus grande
fermeté lorsque l'on s'attaque à un élu
lorsqu'on s'attaque à un représentant de
la nation
t'as qu'à la démocratie on s'attaque à
la capacité de pouvoir débattre tous
ensemble mais n'y ait à ce point la
responsabilité du président de la
république est totalement inconscient
elle le sait très bien il a attisé la
flamme c'est un pompier pyromane il veut
attisées et monter les uns contre les
autres pour ensuite dire regardez à quel
point nous sommes attaqués mais bien sûr
on le cite la situation est tendue
raison pour laquelle et je le redis la
ici j'ai voté moi même contre le pass
vaccinale parce que vous essayez vous
avec votre majorité avec le président de
la république de contraindre les
français là où il faut les convaincre
contre après ce qui s'est passé ou par
conviction
j'ai voté contre parce que depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire je ne
crois pas que nous ré nous réussissions
à lutter contre ces petites épidémies en
réduisant les libertés preuve en est le
pass and i ter qui a effectivement
poussé à la vaccination je le note mais
qui pour autant n'a absolument pas
endigué la presse donc il est très clair
que le post vaccinale qui encore plus
restrictif peu le pass and it et ne
résoudra préfet remet en rien le nom de
contamination augmente les restrictions
les port du masque les jauges et cetera
s'applique encore plus sur notre
territoire donc le pass vaccinale n'est
clairement pas la solution en tout état
de cause le tour vaccinale n'est pas la
solution il faut élargir les
possibilités pour lutter la pendue
contre la pandémie la fin aux débats sur
la pandémie on va rester justement sur
sur ces violences je voudrais qu'on voit
les chiffres entre janvier et novembre
dernier
1186 élus ont été ciblés par ces
violences et une augmentation de 47 % en
un an rémy rebeyrotte là pour le coup
hors propos évidemment du chef de l'état
c'est quand même un phénomène assez
inquiétant
oui bien sûr que c'est un phénomène
inquiétant qui ne vise pas d'ailleurs
que parlait que des parlementaires vous
avez aujourd'hui tu aimais reçues
protested met en place de maxi d'auto
des personnes qui sous prétexte qu'il
coordonne l'action des vaccinodromes
olivia master qui sont attaqués c'est
proprement inacceptable
et encore je dis à la collègue n'y a pas
de noms mais c'est condamnable
répréhensible de faire à ce jeu
j'aimerais tout simplement sur la
question de de
vote sur le kazakh sinan jeu certes elle
fait partie de ceux qui n'ont pas suivi
les consignes et compris de son parti
politique et de la leader quel soutien
pour les présidentielles c'est vrai que
nous avons tous été un peu surpris de
voir 75% du groupe l herbe pas botté sur
la consigne qui était celle de madame
pécresse c'est à dire de soutenir le
pass vaccinale ça montre bien c'est une
autre forme de violence en politique
quand on commence à l'intérieur même des
ou pas si dispersé à cette manière là et
à ne pas partager du tout les mêmes
points de vue alors même d'ailleurs
alors même d'ailleurs que la candidate
de la leader du pack moi je vais vous
dire avait laissé non seulement mais
dans les discussions qu'il y a toujours
eu entre le gouvernement et tous les
partis politiques tous les responsables
politiques contra moi ce que vous disiez
toutes les décisions qui ensuite sont
prises en conseil de défense font
l'objet de discussions de débats de
réception à matignon de l'ensemble des
acteurs et bien ça n'était pas
apparemment c'est ce qu'on nous dit ce
qui était tout à fait prévu du côté du
groupe et l'air dont acte alors pour
répondre brièvement une lambelin et on
va poursuivre sur le déplacement des
manèges macro hier à nice oui merci
beaucoup je vais répondre avec grand
plaisir mais mon cher collègue je vous
invite déjà à réécouter valérie pécresse
qui a non seulement dit qu'elle était
peut-être d'accord et
sous ce principe du pass vaccinale mais
avec des restrictions et avec un certain
nombre de conditions travail qui est en
train d'être fait avec le sénat et puis
sincèrement lorsque on est député de la
majorité que durant cinq ans on en
arrive à une situation où on est à ce
point on est à ce point de niveau de
violence à l'égard des représentants de
la nation oui pardon de vous dire que je
ne suis pas une député godillot j'ai été
élu par les français je te soutiens
effectivement valérie pécresse mais
effectivement aujourd'hui il y as pour
chacun pour l'un et l'eau d'entre nous
une situation de crise à gérer et je
crois qu'en conscience lorsque nous
sommes député de la nation nous pouvons
aussi voté donc essayer de chercher des
dissensions entre les uns et les autres
c'est vraiment de la petite politique
sincèrement valérie pécresse l'a
expliqué les une position de cohérence
qui a été prise pour les uns et pour les
autres et dans la plus grande des
majorités le groupe mehri publics à ne
s'est pas opposée au pass vaccinale
comme valérie pécresse le porte dans sa
campagne
simplement elle pas comme ça à l' hôtel
sécuritaire c'est quand même ce débat ce
matin emmanuel macron en campagne à nice
hier sur le thème de la sécurité après
le karcher ressorti par valérie pécresse
il a donc été accueillie chaleureusement
par son soutien le maire de nice
christian estrosi mais boycottée par le
député des alpes-maritimes eric ciotti
lui soutien de valérie pécresse regarder
je ne me rendrais pas au déplacement du
candidat macron au futur hôtel des
polices de nice qui n'a même pas de
permis de construire
la visite d'un village potemkine ne
masquera pas le waterloo sécuritaire
d'un quinquennat pour rien en matière de
sécurité alors avant de réagir à ce qu'a
dit eric ciotti rémy rebeyrotte emmanuel
macron était et elle était en campagne
hier à nice
non le président de la république venait
sur un territoire annoncé une très bonne
nouvelle bien sûr la création d'un
nouvel hôtel de police c'est quand même
une très bonne nouvelle quand un
territoire il a rappelé que c'est ce que
dit eric ciotti notamment 1
c'est juste une première pierre fictive
puisque le projet ne verra pas le jour
avant deux ans à priori
oui vous savez les investissements
publics on est tous passés pour le
savoir ça prend un certain temps ce qui
est important c'est de les lancer et
dernière de les réalités ce sera le cas
de police de nice je crois d'ailleurs
plus s'ils restent rosicky est le maire
de nice ne laissera pas de toute façon
père s'il y avait le moindre retard et
caressons
pour son territoire moi ce que je veux
surtout souligné je ne suis pas surpris
de la position de ces ch'tis en saône et
loire nous avons le maire de chalon sur
saône ce plat très proches de monsieur
ciotti qui n'accueille aucun ministre
sur son territoire quand ils se
déplacent mais pas depuis cinq ans
depuis j'allais dire 2012 et peut-être
peut-être avant il était maire en 2014
mais des charmants des maires il ne
venait pas ou visites sur le terrain de
tous qui incarne la république il a
d'ailleurs une relation très
particulière avec ce préfet bon y'a des
gens qui ne sont pas républicains bon
c'est comme ça c'est une fois de qualité
pour vous on a chez les républicains on
est forcément c'est une faute politique
pour vous rémy en revendre de ne pas
avoir été présent à ce déplacement du
chef de l'état un toujours quand le chef
de l'état quel qu'il soit j'étais maire
17 ans j'ai reçu à autun brice hortefeux
j'ai reçu à autun saviez bertrand
lorsqu'il s'agissait de l'hôpital nord
quand on est élu sur un territoire comme
partage pas les opinions plan national
c'est une chose mais que l'on se déplace
pas pour la république
cinq armes sur son territoire et qu'en
plus elle vient apporter un certain
nombre de nouvelles quel que soit
j'allais dire la sensibilité qui peut
être la nôtre la république d'abord je
le dis très clairement et ça c'est ça
n'est pas tolérable de ne pas se
déplacer pour le territoire tout
simplement parce que c'est un c'est un
bien pour le territoire on sait habitant
ça n'est pas tolérable de faire cette
politique de la chaise vide à north
plains comment est ce que vous avez vu
en tout cas perçu ce déplacement du chef
de l'état après les propos notamment de
valérie pécresse qui a dégainé la
première sur ce thème de la sécurité
mais à l'évidence le président de la
république est en campagne nous allons
assister durant les prochains mois
évidemment un certain nombre de pose de
première pierre alors là c'était dans
les alpes maritimes mais je suis prêt à
mettre ma main à couper que dans le
maine et loire nous aurons aussi la pose
de la première pierre d'une prison dont
parlons depuis des dizaines d'années
donc bien sûr que le président de la
république est en campagne les depuis
d'ailleurs juillet puisqu'il distribuer
l'argent public à la manière d'un
candidat donc tous les jours vous avez
droit à une nouvelle dépense il guère
d'ailleurs mais je regrette quand même
ne pas entendre sur le cri moi mon
[Musique]
oui bien sûr bien sûr mais qu'a t'il
fait et c'est d'ailleurs la prolongation
du débat que nous avons eus précédemment
s'était qualifié pendant cinq ans c'est
à dire qu'à un moment donné la sécurité
là une séquence sécurité en pleine
campagne c'est une chose mais lorsque
l'on est président sortant on porte une
certaine responsabilité
aujourd'hui les français ont besoin de
rigueur ont besoin d'avoir une justice
et une sécurité une police qui
fonctionne de pair on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui des problèmes de
d'effectivité des peines sont
se sont avérées dans l'exécution des
décisions du site oui je vous vois
hausse et des yeux mon cher collègue
mais à l'évidence on voit bien que les
moyens à la fois pour la gendarmerie
pour la police ne sont non pas été mis
totalement sûr sur le tapis comme on
pourrait dire et puis surtout qu'il ya
un problème de sanctions dans ce pays
voilà les sanctions ne sont pas
appliquées pas correctement appliqué et
pas suffisamment dur pour que signé
effectivement une délinquance qui soit
moins élevé donc aujourd'hui bien sûr
que le président de la république est en
campagne et il utilise les moyens de
l'état clairement pour propager la bonne
parole d'un candidat
je rappelle juste les mesures 15
milliards 15 milliards d'euros sur cinq
ans doubler le nombre de policiers sur
le terrain d'ici à cinq ans doubler les
enquêtes en cinq ans sur les violences
intrafamiliales généraliser les amendes
forfaitaires et triplé notamment
l'amande pour harcèlement de rue à 300
euros une loi de programmation qui sera
annoncé en fin de mandat c'est plutôt
bizarre et nient regrette une loi de
programmation en fin de mandat
exactement c'est d'ailleurs ce que je
voulais regarder
et vous réagirez après la langue là
oui c'est un travail de fond qui étaient
engagées depuis maintenant de nombreuses
années autour de ce qu'on appelle le bon
goût de la sécurité donc nous arrivons
aujourd'hui aux conclusions de ce long
processus et effectivement il ya des
conséquences mais pour autant pour
autant depuis le début du mandat parce
que il faut quand même dire les choses
nous sommes nous sortons la demande à
manger parler de dinan où on a augmenté
considérablement le nombre de forces de
l'ordre police et jean sur notre
territoire où nous avons modernisé aller
au jour dans les commissariats dans les
gendarmeries modernisée du matériel qui
avait pour le moins ces dames en
souffert et qui n'était plus du tout à
niveau je rappelle aussi que
contrairement au diénat
une petite rupture a malheureusement
c'est l'occasion pour vous un ordre de 1
de réagir justement à ces mesures
annoncées par emmanuel macron
effectivement c'est jj penser tout à
l'heure mais tout à l'heure ce que vous
avez dit sur l' annonce du projet de loi
de programmation voilà on est
typiquement dans une annonce qui ne sera
pas suivie d'effet puisque il en aura
pas le temps et pour autant il va faire
croire aux français qu'il va encore
réagir sur la sécurité alors que ce
n'est pas le cas tout loi aura sera voté
a priori cette loi sera votée mais
tombera avec la législature plus que
dans tout état de cause il y aura le
renouvellement de l'assemblée nationale
à moins que il prévoit de reconvoquer
parlement entre l'élection
présidentielle et l'élection législative
vraisemblablement pour la gestion de la
crise sanitaire sont n'était pas le cas
vont a priori pour les questions de
sécurité
alors qu'on pourrait le faire dès
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas enfin ce
sera très certainement compliqué donc
voilà tout ça et tout ça sont des
déclarations d'intention je regrette que
mes collègues suivent la majorité et
suivent le président de la république
avec les yeux aussi fermé parce que je
crois qu'on attend et les français
attendent de leurs représentants une
clairvoyance
mais c'est quand même parce qu'on a été
interrompue par dont un parent dont anne
leur bla il nous reste deux minutes donc
rémy rebeyrotte je vous laisse
poursuivre sur cette loi de
programmation on a une rupture de
faisceau malheureusement
oui excusez moi oui non simplement je
voulais dire d'abord ma collec
je sais pas si nous avons un soin de
députés qui ne soit aux godillots mais
ce que nous avons besoin cette cohérence
et cohésion et ça si on pouvait la voir
chez les alertes vais vous dire que la
semaine dernière ça nous aurait tous les
uns les autres et la république arrange
deuxième deuxième élément pour faire
c'est à dire que on ne vient pas
évidemment le beauvau via encore
accélérer les choses et des décisions
qui vont être prises mais c'est j'allais
dire incroyable de ne pas voir combien
il suffit d'interroger des forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain les choses se
sont déjà amélioré en nombre de
personnes moi je j'ai un commissariat
dans ma circonscription
on est revenus à la situation
est allé dire d'avant
2007 c'est à dire avant qu on détricote
à certain nombre de moyens avec des
personnels en moins sur ce commissariat
et avec du personnel qui dit alors ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut se contenter de
retricoter simplement mais il faut bien
sûr mettre des moyens supplémentaires
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le chef de l'état
il faut travailler là dessus de la même
manière nous avons à prendre corps la
question de la justice là encore ça
n'est pas simple vous avez vu que ça
bouge forcément y compris dans le auprès
des professions judiciaires parce que
c'est pas simple mettre en cause un
certain nombre d'organisations
d'habitude et quelquefois de de
manque de moyens on a vu la tribune des
3000 magistrat qui qui qui demandaient
des meilleures conditions de travail
également et oui donc aujourd'hui tout
cela est engagé forcément que vous
mettez des choses en mouvement elle
bouge y compris d'ailleurs dans des
logiques un peu de confrontation mais
pendant 30 ans dans ce pays
avant le président macro on n'avait rien
voulu toucher on ne réforme est pas au
faisait semblant de réformer oui c'est
un peu difficile sacré du mouvement mais
dans un pays si nécessaire de raison
merci beaucoup ce sera le mot de la fin
on n'a plus le temps malheureusement
merci en tout cas tous les deux d'être
venus débattre à distance dans cette
matinale d'ayrté france